Cinnabon is vile. It's not.
I stand by it. But I do love cinnamon rolls.
So we got all these cinnamon rolls to try.
These are my favorite ones.
Already had. What?
How many did you have? Like, three today.
These are all the ones that I wanted to try.
So we had the original ones,
but these are, like,
different flavors. We got them at a little bakery,
and these are my absolute favorite ones.
American cinnamon rolls could never. Okay.
Yes, they can. Cinnabon.
These don't have any frosting on it,
so that's the issue.
This is just the plain one.
Okay. We have multiple different ones.
These are my favorite ones.
I think about them every time.
But let's see what else we have.
Okay. Chocolate.
And then this one is. Got so much personality today. This.
Let me take it out.
Chocolate and vanilla. Absolutely not.
Strawberry. Strawberry.
Try again.
Apricot.
Apricot. How'd you get apricot from that?
This is white chocolate and raspberry,
which I'm very intrigued by.
This one I'm a little apprehensive about.
It's pumpkin something.
I'm not quite sure exactly what it is,
but doesn't scream like my cup of tea.
But they said it was a really good one.
So you wanna start with. I will start with.
This is what we're gonna start with.
We're gonna start with the worst.
So, pumpkin.
Okay.
I'm not a huge fan of pumpkin.
It's too big of a bite. Cheers.
Haha.
No one Out of 10,
what do you rate it? 3. Okay.
I don't think we got the raspberry.
I got it. You did?
Hundred percent. What do you rate this one, though? Did you rate it?
Let's try the chocolate. I'm not a huge fan of chocolate.
Or chocolate desserts.
Oh, I'm a little nervous.
Are you shaking any boots?
Alright, this one has potential.
Hmm. I like it.
Quite chocolatey. Need a drink to cleanse my palate.
I read that. Cleanse your palate, babe.
What do you rate it? Uh, five.
I'm not a big fan of these.
I'll be honest with you.
5 5 as well. And you know that this one's gonna slap.
This is the star of the show.
Okay. Sometimes I feel like if classics are done well,
you don't need to deviate.
This one's just beautiful.
Okay, we've already had three of these today.
Good. Isn't that stunning?
Hmm.
A 7. A solid 7.3621.
I rate it a 9. This is so good.
It's good. It's just.
And also needs to be warmed up.